hallo mein name ist newcomer der liebe
freunde ich darf mich heute mal wieder
recht herzlich willkommen heißen zu
einer neuen episode ebay fails mit mir
weil wetters ist logischerweise immer
noch immer meinen kann man bei diesem
ersten ebay verkauft jemand einen rex 50
motorroller und ein interessent fragt
hallo wie sieht es mit 50 euro aus und
er schickt daraufhin ein foto vom roller
mit 50 euro
bei diesen nächsten die bergwelt
verkauft eine person einen großen
spiegel für einen 15 euro verhandelbaren
kreis und das hier ist
das foto irgendwie sieht aus wie eine
jugendherberge 2004 neil turok ich weiß
wirklich nicht wie man einen spiegel
fotografieren soll wenn man sich selbst
nicht zeigen will dann muss man sich ja
irgendwas auf ok oder man macht halt ein
foto von der seite fragt jemand hallo
haben sie die hose auch in größe 48
liebe grüße der verkäufer der hose
antwortete auf dem guten abend tut mir
leid nein ich verkaufe hier nur diese
eine rose der interessent stadt
daraufhin verständnisvoll ich verstehe
arschloch
ok ich dachte man alle aber ich glaube
es von automatischen sich euro und beim
nächsten ebay kleinanzeigen verkauft
jemand eine hermès tasche für 1500 euro
er liest ja eigentlich auch mal als
erstes hermes
irgendwann besten scheiß laden
ausgesucht oder gab es hermes zuerst ist
auf jeden fall verkauft jemand hier auf
jeden fall der herr mit er mit ms evil
tasche bekommen haben wir auch so
komischen namen
warum heißen taschen nicht so wie
iphones so hermès
12 und wenn sie dann in größter gibt
dann heißt die zwei pro max
auf jeden fall hat er das foto dieser ms
steven tasche für 1500 euro natürlich
selbstverständlich in dem privatjet
aufgenommen wie ihr verkauft eure im
estischen nicht aus dem privat
geringverdiener beim nächsten liebefeld
verkauft eine person eine xbox und er
schreibt einem interessenten der die
xbox kaufen möchte bin ab viertel nach
drei zuhause der interessen antwortet
darauf hin ich frag meinen vater ok zwei
stunden später schreibt die person hat
allerdings auch habe die xbox für 130
verkauft tut mir leid wenn vater hat es
mir sowieso nicht erlaubt hat gesagt die
sollen politiker werden da kann ich mir
alles leisten
verdienen politiker viel geld
er gut wahrscheinlich so unter der hand
so ein bisschen vom unternehmen xy lobby
komm mach mal die studie und dauert oft
bei diesem ebay foto hier denkt man sich
vielleicht erst mal das verkauft jemand
gegen die alkohol oder generell getränke
oder zumindest den pfand oder sucht eine
person die aufräumen nach einer party
mehr verschenkt einfach einen freitags
so bei ihm zu hause
was ist die adresse
beim nichts wie waffeln verkauft eine
person einen schrank und ein interessent
rakim halo ist noch da ich kann morgen
um 9 uhr abholen hallo müsste allerdings
selber abgebaut werden ja gerne sendet
sie die adresse bitte ich komme mit zwei
personen und ein felix
ziemlich hatte es an felix ist ja nicht
zu den personen gezielt oder ein
schlechtes auto und ich komme zwei
personen und felix der kukksi umwelten
wissen will und spielkind diese
hundebesitzer die sagen der windows
spielen
ich bilde mir klar ich auch wenn meine
zehen und reißt das beinhaus von
irgendwelchen kindern alten ich mir
damals passiert und jeder kratzer noch
am rücken und im grünen kötter trotzdem
will ich mir im nächsten jahr und wollen
ist aber ein anderes thema meine lieben
freunde ich würde sagen der unteren
versammelt viele fans nämlich
capri-sonne kirche mit plastik strohhalm
selten wird hier verkauft für sage und
schreibe denkt man sich vielleicht
irgendwie 30 euro oder sogar schon 400
ja ich muss auch erstmal mussten ihr
verkauft jemand ein 13 zoll macbook air
und ein interessent fragt den verkäufer
haben was ich sehr letzte preis halo 3
oder 20 euro sind sie zu hoch schreibt
er daraufhin und der gunner antwortet
bin ein meter 90 groß hatte bisher keine
probleme hahaha ich meinte den preis und
daraufhin
misst er die höhe des geldes schreibt
doch dazu ist nicht hoch und
sehr interessant antwortet nur verstehe
ich schwöre ich liebe solche dummen und
haltungen
soll ich mich mal
sondern erst mal angehen dass ich mich
wirklich mal selber bei der anmeldung
ein paar leute verarschen
schreibe es in die kommentare ob er bock
drauf hätte dann leichter ist über die
feiertage hoch und bier verkauft jemand
einen 10 alhambra brutale karte für 2000
euro dann denkt man sich wahrscheinlich
decker brutale karte was das ferrari 2.0
fast
generell hamas aber auch mit autos
irgendwie bei ebay immer hier verkaufte
mich mal einen opel corsa findet war
handelbaren preis und das ist das foto
da würde ich eher laufen wobei
allerdings gab schon beim thema autos in
meine lieben freunde dieses auto hier
wird als nächstes verkauft und zwar ist
es eine rollen des stücks mit glücklos
wunschpaket kein scherz für 100.000 euro
pro der mission menschen echt gesehen
ziemlich abgeschlossen sehe ich
eigentlich schon wieder aus man hier
verschenkt jemand einen tisch mit
gebrauchsspuren oder interessant
schreibt ich muss habe den tisch wo
stehe ich auch kaufen stuhl da halo
biete auf rück wörter
alle angaben stehen in der anzeige warum
anzeige bieten nix polizei
als nächstes verkaufte jemand einen glas
tisch mit einer kaputt optik für 50 euro
da fragt wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
erstmal so mensch es gibt ja auch
kunstwerke gemalte bilder wo alles ein
bisschen aufgeraut ist das ein bisschen
kaputt aussehen soll und vielleicht ist
es ja auch eine art von kunst nee
der ist einfach wirklich schrott sowie
mein content nicht nur hier sondern auch
auf tik tok und instagram
da es sich so
haben wir übrigens auch ein neues laptop
hoch geladen wo ich essen falschen
gestern zum beispiel die bananenschale
oder avocado kern schon vorbei auf dem
klavier verkauft jemand neue lederschuhe
super latschen herne 46 in braun und
zwar ein richtiges sammlerstück für
allerdings nur einen euro da fragt er
sich jetzt wahrscheinlich menschen in
iso super latschen sind unseren
sammlerstücke wie sehen die denn aus so
ich sag's wie es ist wenn irgendwer von
euch solche latschen trägt bitte diaboli
mit hier verkauft jemand einen thermomix
allerdings ein altes modell da ist
allerdings für nur 10 euro drin stand
wegen bisschen hellhörig geworden habe
mir gedacht ist das wirklich einen
thermomix na ja
eher aus wie eine kaffeemaschine mit
britischen bands dringt darauf fressen
diese briten eigentlich bohnen zum
frühstück als erster durch das heutige
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch die bergwelt
mit luca endlich mal wieder auf einem
kanal gefallen hat das kann einen daumen
hoch und die mitte hier abonnieren kann
ein und klickt auf die glocke wenn der
neue videos nicht verpassen wollt
vielleicht dann auch unter anderem das
video die tage wo ich mich selber mal
bei ebay anmelde welche das machen soll
schreibt die kommentare bringen welche
tipps tricks hinweise wünsche was ich
dann machen soll schreibt und in die
kommentare und wir
befinden uns jetzt ein auto
ihr könnt jetzt ihr irgendwie mich
abonnieren und hier ich bin ein anderes
video angucken